Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P
Here's a really good question that came in
about the obsession from many on the. Right.
With trans people. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hi, David. As for why people are
so obsessed with trans people, I myself am not
trans, but most many of my best friends are.
It's actually really based in white
supremacy in that being a straight white man
is their entire identity. And if the gender binary
it doesn't exist the way they think it does, then
their entire life is an entire existential crisis
that they can't deal with because their entire
identity is based on being a straight white man.
So it's a lot more complicated than that. And
the gender binary is very complicated across
multiple cultures, but that's my $0.02.
Speaker 1: So there's a couple different
things going on. First of all, I think
some people don't like it when I say this.
I really could not care less about gender
and sexuality in the sense of it impacting my
opinion or conversations that I want to have
with people. And what I mean by that is I
I'm not being pejorative when I say this.
I'm really bored by all of this stuff of what
identity and who's what and who do you date and
who are you attracted to and what's your gender?
I have so many things that I tend to find of
interest to talk about with people regardless
of their identity. That I find all of this stuff
really, really boring. I treat everybody with
respect. I don't care how you want to identify.
I don't care who you're attracted to. I just
it's just not interesting to me. I consider
all of these just people's personal choices,
and I'm fine with whatever as long as you're not
hurting people committing crimes. The things I'm
concerned with are people who, regardless of their
identity, are just not good people. That those are
my concerns. So for me, it's like I just I just
don't care. Do whatever you want, see whoever.
Okay. Now, that doesn't mean I ignore the fact
that there are people targeted and treated
terribly because of their identity. Now, why is
it such a point of obsession for so many on the
right? Right now, it's trans people. It's it's in
a sense, there's two things going on. One. It is
much more what's the word I'm going to say? It's
it's now much more accepted to be gay and lesbian,
by the way. Lesbianism has for a long time been
the most accepted. That's the least offensive.
That's for a long time. If you could sort of like
rank the things that the homophobic, transphobic,
etc., right wingers are angry about lesbians is
usually the thing that they're least angry about.
Then you've got gay people, and when it comes to
gay men, they have to a great degree kind of said,
okay, gay marriage is legal. You can't fire people
for their real or perceived sexual orientation
anymore. We got to kind of ease up on that. And
also, I think that the public opinion has shifted
and more and more people, even right wingers,
are generally tolerant, if not absolutely fine
with gay people as a general thing, although
homophobia still exists. So now you've got trans,
and within trans you have a number of different
aspects that people can choose to become enraged
about. There's the trans adoption part. There is
the characterizing trans people as predators. This
is the bathroom staff. Remember, that was when
bathrooms were the big flashpoint. It was all
about, well, biological men will lie, that they
are actually wanting to exist in the world as
women simply to go hang out in women's bathrooms
and girls locker rooms. And it's like, of course,
that's not happening. And also acting like a
predator would get you in trouble no matter what
you have as gender identity. It didn't make any
sense, but that was one aspect that they could.
They've been pushing the gay men or pedophiles
thing for a long time, wrongly so. But it seemed
like they had a really specific way to do it with
trans people that was less overtly transphobic
to some and so they could get away with it.
I think that that's one component of it.
Number two, it's entered the political milieu for
the right because of trans sports and Donald Trump
openly, you know, doing his weightlifting, mimicry
and the entire thing about trans sports. So as
another aspect that is entered in, if you have a
competition among men and some of the men are gay,
it doesn't give you the same opportunity to claim
things are unfair that the narrative about trans
athletes has given. So that's sort of like another
aspect to it. And then beyond that, they they seem
obsessed to some degree because the focus has
been on cultural issues more specifically lately.
And so they don't really have policy to talk
about. I think it's sort of like a little bit
of all of the above. That's why the right has
become so obsessed with with trans people. If
there's elements of it that are missing, let me
know. We have a great bonus show for you today,
Andrew Yang's foreword party, the third party has
now formally launched. We will talk about it. What
is their policy? We don't know yet, but they're
going to announce it very, very soon. Secondly,
the Biden administration is offering to
return to Russia, a convicted arms dealer,
to get Brittney Griner back. That's the female
basketball player who's been imprisoned in
Russia for a period of time now. There is now
a negotiation happening. We will talk about it.
And number three, two former police officers have
now been sentenced for violating George Floyd's
civil rights. This is going above and beyond the
initial trial and we will talk about that as well.
All of those stories and more are available on
today's bonus show. To get the bonus show, you've
got to be a member. That's the only requirement
you sign up at join Pacman dot com. You will
instantly have access to the bonus show. And
of course, if you would like a discount off of
membership, use the coupon code. Big voting
22. We will see you then or on the price.